hello everybody
i'm kim goff cruz secretary and vice
president for university life
and the senior officer in charge of the
belonging at yale initiative
this event is the first in a series of
events
on anti-racism that is being done in
conjunction with the belonging a.l
initiative
this is the university's major
initiative to create a climate of
belonging for
all of us faculty students staff and
alumni
the series is open to all staff students
faculty and alumni
and on december 2nd we'll host our
second speaker
dr ibrahim x kendi historian and author
of how to be an anti-racist
today over 800 people register for this
conversation
and most of our guests are staff so
special welcome to you
many thanks to deborah stanley mccauley
who is the associate vice president
for employee engagement and workplace
culture
and of course her team for their
generous support of this event
our guest today is dr dolly chug
social psychologist nyu stern school of
business associate professor
and the author of the person you mean to
be
how good people fight bias and her book
dr chug provides practical applications
to
evidence-based research that can help us
address our own biases
in our personal lives and in our
workplace she helps us understand
how we can be better by practicing
vulnerability
understanding our privilege making
mistakes and learning
from them with a growth mindset she
reminds us that we have
things to learn all of us we are not
always the people we mean to be
or even think we are but most of us are
good people trying to do better
dr laurie santos will facilitate the
conversation and will incorporate
questions that have been submitted in
advance
now she doesn't need an introduction but
i am going to say a few words for the
few of you who don't know her
dr santos is the aeo professor of
psychology
and head of silliman college she hosts
the very popular podcast
the happiness lab and is the director of
the comparative cognition
laboratory and the canine cognition
center at yale
her course psychology and the good life
is the most popular course
ever taught at yale it's my pleasure to
turn the
program over to dr santos to introduce
dr chug
and begin what i know is going to be a
really informative conversation
thank you so much kim for that
introduction and thanks so much for
having me at this first panel
on belonging at yale i'm so i'm super
thrilled to be part of it
um kim already gave you a quick
introduction to dolly chug's work but
since i
love her and her work so much i couldn't
help but kind of tell you a little bit
more about what she's been up to
um as mentioned dolly is a associate
professor at new york
at nyu stern school of business but her
work really focuses on this problem of
what it means to be a good person and
the psychological mechanisms that make
up being a good person
um her book the person you mean to be
how good people fight bias is one of my
favorite books out there
um and you should definitely check it
out you should also check out her
newsletter
which is called dear good people you can
sign up at dollychuck.com
newsletter and it is fantastic because
while her book is a whole host of
insights and a book length worth
of wonderful tips for how you can kind
of fight bias all the time
her newsletter will give you one
actionable tip every single time you
receive it and it's a fantastic way to
kind of keep up with your anti-racism
efforts
but it's also worth noting just how
important dolly has been in this fight
so far and just how much of an impact
she's had
as with most people dolly has had an
amazing number of accolades way too many
to list here
but it's worth noting that she is listed
as one of the top 100 most influential
people in business ethics by ethisphere
magazine
i'll point out that this is a list that
also includes people like pope francis
angelina jolie and bill gates you get a
sense of her
kind of influence here she's also an
amazing teacher she's been one of the
most highly rated business school
professors at nyu for a long time
and just this year she received the 2020
nyu distinguished teaching award
she's just an amazing teacher and an
amazing mentor and an amazing person in
terms of her impact
and today we're really going to kind of
dive deep into her work we're going to
talk not just about the kinds of things
we need to do
to focus on becoming better people but
we're going to explore how her work
demonstrates that all of us really need
to step it up if we want to kind of
create the change that we want to see in
our world
if we want to have just societies and
just organizations and
just universities then we really need to
do something
and one of the things we need to do is
to understand the biases that we're all
walking around with we need to hack
those biases and understand how they
work
so that we can become better people and
so with that i'm super excited to
introduce dolly i'm such a huge fan and
i'm thrilled that yale has brought her
here today
please join me in welcoming dr dolly
chug
hi lori thanks so much for coming again
oh my god so so i wanted to start out
with maybe what's an obvious question so
uh you know we have a lot of people on
this call but i i hope i can speak
for all of them when i say that
everybody on this call
like truly cares about equity like
everybody on this call i hope
believes that people from all races all
ethnicities you know all
all body statuses all that stuff should
be treated equally
but what you argue in your book is that
that belief in equity
isn't enough and is in fact part of the
problem so
walk me through why believing isn't
enough oh okay great
thank you for having me lori colleagues
it's wonderful to be here
um well i i talk about this difference
between being
a believer and a builder and i say this
from a place of frankly seeing myself
and exactly what i'm about to describe
so um as you just listed there's a whole
range of ways in which a lot of us want
to see
equality and even equity in the world
around us
and we believe that's what we what what
should happen
we also are believers that that doesn't
exist so we don't have to be convinced
uh we we may not be deeply informed on
every issue and every identity but
but we know that things aren't quite
where we want them to be we're believers
in that sense the challenge however
is that the status quo doesn't change
based on our beliefs necessarily
particularly if artwork we're really
kind of invested in being the kind of
people who believe that and i i think i
am i really want to be
the kind of person who um treats people
well
that that creates opportunities for
people who haven't had opportunities
i want to be that kind of believer
however in order to do it i have to
build certain things i have to build
knowledge
i have to build skills i have to build
systems i have to build courage i have
to build
habits these are all active um
modes of operating that won't happen
just because i believe something so just
because i believe
uh every student in my class at nyu
should be treated equally and should
have an equal opportunity to succeed in
my class
that doesn't mean that i have built a
system in which that can happen
and that i've built a classroom in which
everyone feels equally welcome
that i've built a grading protocol in
which everyone has
the possibility to excel that i've built
a culture
in which people feel they can come talk
to me if they have a question
those are all actions i have to take so
the distinction between believing and
building or really i shouldn't call it
distinction the continuum between
moving from being a believer to a
builder for me is about
taking actions and the the challenge
with
when we don't do that when we sit in
that believer end of the pool
is that we get comfortable we we care so
much about this
issue that we develop an identity as
being someone supportive of this
issue but not doing anything about it
and if someone says hey
how about you know i noticed um there
are ways in which maybe you're
contributing to the challenge like
if if my teaching assistant says to me
um
i noticed that your calling patterns
reflect you calling on
men more than women which happened uh
that's true
um that then i'm gonna get defensive
because i'm like well no i believe in
equity in my classroom
and uh rather than building saying ah
okay now i have data
what can i do with this data what can i
do to change my calling patterns
what can i do to make it possible for
more people to have their hands up
that's what the builder response is as
opposed to the believer response
and i think this is so important because
again you know i'm sure everybody who's
coming to this is coming from this place
of like caring about this stuff
yes i think that's super important that
the caring alone it's not just like
not helpful it could actually be deeply
counterproductive to some interesting
extent
and in fact it feels like abandonment i
think when when we're
when we're part of the groups that are
dealing with this if you
if you're if you're um a black student
at yale
and your white classmates believe in all
this but aren't
taking action on it it feels like
abandonment
it doesn't feel like support at all i'm
not of course speaking for everyone but
but in general that that's the
perception um
that both science and anecdotes would
suggest so
that's the danger of being a believer is
that that it's
it feels uh shallow we're in the shallow
end of the pool
and so you talked about a couple
different ways that we can kind of dive
into the deeper end of the pool right
that there's kind of different ways to
be a builder um with a kind of like like
really hardcore building and a kind of
softer
type of building so talk about in your
book you make this distinction between
light and heat which i think is a really
great analogy so walk me through kind of
the light version of building versus the
heat version of building
yeah absolutely and i'm going to preface
this by saying it's the most important
thing about light and heat is to know
that we need both
uh let me let me define what each of
them mean i'm using a metaphor i wasn't
able to track down who
originally came up with this light heat
metaphor it's widely used
um the idea of when you take a light
based approach to let's say
making change in your community or in
your institution
you you meet people where they are you
center
their comfort you um you educate
you teach uh it's it's it's
it's slower and it's more incremental
a heat-based approach to making change
is one in which
by definition it is not centering the
comfort of others it is
pushing it is disruptive um
and it's meant to push for change faster
in a more dramatic ways
most of us my sense is kind of lean in
terms of our personal preferences
towards more light or more heat i mean
some people are good at both and
comfortable with both but
like i would say i i tend to lean
towards the light based approaches
but this was a really i would say
probably the most important learning i
had from writing this book
was realizing that just because i am
more comfortable with
light doesn't mean that i don't i
shouldn't see the value in heat
what historians have showed us showed us
historians of social movements is that
when a movement sort of leans heavily on
light or
leans heavily on heat versus movements
that balance
both the movements that balance both
make more progress so
the message here and this is why i feel
so important for me to learn this
is just because i am a light based
person
doesn't mean that i shouldn't be
cheering on
the heat based folks and just because
i'm a heat based folks
he's heat based person doesn't mean i
shouldn't be cheering on the light base
we often feel the tactics being used by
by the others
aren't what we would do and aren't as
effective but
one of the differences that light and
heat has
and why we need both is that light may
be more likely to change
minds but it's probably not going to
change systems
heat's probably more likely to change
systems and less likely to change
minds well we need both we need both
our minds and our systems to to move
in order for real change to happen and
so i think in this work of being a
builder
sometimes we preference you know because
i'm right-handed i want everyone to be
right-handed or because i'm left i don't
want everybody left-handed
but no what we want is light-based
people to cheer on the heat-based people
and heat-based people that share on the
light-based people and frankly
it's all good wherever you are in that
space as long as you're not in the
in action you know that's back to being
a believer you know i don't know
keep the metaphor going like darkness if
you will or silence or something
um but but the the light and heat are
both important it's particularly
important that we cheer on the heat i
think
i don't have data on this but i bet
there's more light based people
in your community than there are
heat-based and
boy you should be grateful that you have
those heat-based folks
that's perfect and so i mean so both of
us need to kind of as you said get past
the darkness like we need the light in
the heat but people can't be sort of
sitting around in the dark and so
one of the first skill sets you you
present in the book
for getting people out of the darkness
and again the darkness is believing in
equity right it's like thinking that
that thing's just not dying
the first step is really kind of
learning something right it's actually
recognizing the sorts of privileges that
you have
and so this can be a tricky concept for
people who haven't talked a lot about
this before so walk me through this idea
of privilege what that means
yeah i i i i struggle with this too um
it's tied a lot to another tricky word
which is systemic
i think these words go hand in hand and
and are hard to understand
the the metaphor that helped me with
that came comes from debbie irving
she uses a metaphor of headwinds and
tailwinds that i find really useful
um so i'm looking over there to make
sure my kids aren't eavesdropping
because they'll always laugh with the
little example i'm about to give you
so so the example is let's say i was to
go running
that's when they start laughing they're
like ah let's say
um so let's say i go running and i say
okay i'm gonna run
you know to the high school on the
corner have a good job and then i'm
gonna u-turn and come right back the way
i came
and while i'm i'm making my way over
there i'm i'm feeling pretty good i'm
like
you know i think there's no carb things
working out i'm feeling pretty strong
you know make a good time and then i
turn around for the u-turn
and suddenly things feel harder and more
effortful
and if someone was just like inside
their
their home or office and watching me
through a window
they might if they just see me coming
back be like doesn't even look like
she's trying that hard or she doesn't
look that motivated or i don't maybe she
comes from a community doesn't really
value running i see you know she's just
not taking it seriously
they wouldn't see what i'm feeling which
is a headwind
in my face on the way back and on my way
there
that tailwind which was propelling me
forward i didn't even feel because you
don't really
feel tailwinds you you benefit from them
but you don't feel them
and so the headwinds are more easily
felt than the tailwinds
and and and all of it is sort of
invisible
in general and hard to see and that's i
think a good way to think about what
privilege is is that at any given moment
any one of us has some form of privilege
on some form of our
their identities like i'm i'm straight
and while i don't spend a lot of time
thinking about my straightness because
frankly i don't have to the world is
kind of
at least the community and the society i
live in is makes it pretty easy to be
straight
it doesn't create obstacles for me i
have
lots of legal rights i have lots of
physical safety
um that privilege that i have that
tailwind is one i don't even really
think about um versus the headwind
that that if someone isn't straight
they're constantly navigating
um and so when we talk about privilege
what we're really talking about
are where do we have tailwinds
and each of us have multiple identities
and
and therefore multiple headwinds and
tailwinds in
right now i think in 2020 we've had an
opportunity
there's been headwinds if you are a
black american
um there are headwinds that have been
very visible and
felt by people in the black community
that haven't been
felt and seen and experienced by many
people outside the black community and
that became
visible in a new way in this year for
many people some people already know
so that that that privilege is sort of
one in which we're now tuning into in a
way that maybe
uh at a widespread countrywide basis we
haven't done in the past
but this is kind of the key of these
headwinds and tailwinds is that
that both of them are invisible i mean i
guess i guess the headwinds are very
visible if you're being slowed down by
them right
are incredibly visible to you but if
you're not from a marginalized identity
or or one of your identities is not
marginalized
you just don't see it right and and this
what i love about your book is that you
point out that this is true for you too
right like you do
on this and it's still hard to see these
things absolutely like i have so many
tailwinds
and and you know what whether it's um
me not realizing you know i'm i'm the
child of indian immigrants
um so i was born in india but a baby
when when
my parents came here and and i
you know i think i i don't know what
like i'm not sure how people identify me
i think i pass as a lot of things
um that that privileges me i get i get
considered a person of color in some
circles
in a way that privileges me when i'm
with other people of color and
i think some people see me as white
maybe and i sort of
pass in those circles um there's lots of
ways you know the straightness is
another example
i i think you know my education level my
native language
i'm cisgender none of these identities
are
better than other identities i'm not in
any way saying i'm
lucky to have those identities but i do
incur benefits as a result of those
identities my education my income level
um i i'm constantly surprised at the
things i'm oblivious to
you know the the the fact um you know
most recently the the set of
of awareness that i've gained is around
my
physical abilities and disabilities um
and realizing there's lots of ways in
which i have just
not even noticed how the world is not
set up
for um students in my community in my
classes who are disabled
and that's despite supposed like legal
accommodations that we make that really
i can tell you in my classroom have not
been sufficient and so
uh i've just recently realized there's
all these ways in which i've made
learning harder for my students that i
could have been addressing
like using captions on zoom um like when
i was when we were
teaching in person using captions on
videos
i mean those are just two two of many
ways
um so these these privileges that like
that's a
headwind i was just not seeing at all
yeah and so when you bring up those
examples i think you know everybody who
has those cases where they kind of
notice
like spots where wow i was just having
it so much easier than i even realized
that i'm making it inadvertently harder
for the people around me and i had some
hand in it right it's not just the
system like
right the videos i posted for my class
had that same feature
you sometimes like one bad thing about
privilege is that it's invisible but the
second bad thing about privilege is that
when you notice it
it feels incredibly bad right like even
in cases where you didn't have a hand in
it like you feel kind of awful like i
don't
neces i didn't you know try to get these
tailwinds that are making me speed past
everyone
um and so so talk about that feature of
privilege right because i think
you know a lot of us don't like feeling
like we're getting these
tailwinds that are kind of helping us
out a lot and what does that do to our
psychology
yeah i mean it it's pretty mortifying
right like
and there's there's research that shows
that that we we
actually uh we like to to get things but
we we sort of like to feel like we do
we deserve it and we earned it right
like we don't like to feel like we
unfairly
uh got something and so that yeah it
feels awful
i i think what where we make a lot of
headway
when we have those moments of insight is
if we can
sort of in the mental accounting of that
noticing
put it in the growth bucket this this is
a place of growth
and so you know one thing i've been um
talking about lately is like
if you can't think about a tv show or a
joke
or a word that that you watched or used
or laughed at
a year ago or five years ago that you're
now mortified by
i'm gonna argue there you're not growing
you're not learning
if you feel like everything you've ever
said done or watched
is sort of aligned with who you are now
and what you know now
that says to me there's like this very
static um
you know brittle almost good person
identity that isn't
evolving um in most aspects of our life
we try to get better
all the time we try to you know you try
to you try a recipe you haven't tried
before or at work you try to master a
software system or whatever
in this one area of being a good person
though we view
every mistake as as
a complete condemnation a complete sort
of blanket of shame
you know i i sort of feel myself kind of
get warm and sweaty in those moments
um but what's really helped me and
and the research by carol dweck
psychologist and her co-author
supports this is if we can view things
as growth
not not um sort of in a fixed mindset as
she describes it in which we have
nowhere to go
but we actually view oh i just noticed
like those videos that
that was deeply problematic that was
that was something i
i should have known um i shouldn't have
had by the way there was an email that i
probably dismissed about it
like i really had to be nudged um
that that's a moment for me to say okay
i now
know more than i did a year ago and five
years ago and i'm acting on it
um so i i think we miss an opportunity
to actually feel great about ourselves
in that moment
not feel great that we noticed and
stopped but that we noticed and
learned and acted this is the idea that
you talk a lot about in your book
about not wanting to be a good person
but being a good ish person which i
think people can misconstrue when you
say don't worry about being a good
person when it comes to
social justice right like and explain to
me what you mean by goodish because i
think it's so important
yeah thank you i i i i've got to be more
precise
i've learned on that than i've been in
the past okay so so
so the campaign i'm on is to get us to
stop trying to be good people
but that's not because i want us to
lower our standards
i'm actually making the opposite
argument that our good person identities
are a fixed mindset identity they're
deeply brittle
they're not there's there's no stretch
there to grow and get better
in a growth mindset which i in this
domain i would say is called being
goodish
we're actually actively looking for
those mistakes it's an easter egg hunt
they're out there go
find the candy um candy that's the wrong
that was a terrible metaphor but
but um go go find the learnings
because when you do that's where the
growth happens and so this goodish what
i'm defining as goodish
is being someone who's actively noticing
and actually seeking out those learnings
um you know we know from the studies
around growth mindset that when
you make a mistake in a fixed mindset we
actually see brain activity kind of shut
down
you actually don't attend to the mistake
you literally withdraw
mental attention um versus if you're in
a growth mindset and you make that
mistake we see
all sorts of activity in the brain in a
way that suggests like you may be
mortified but boy are you going to soak
up what you can from this moment
and that's soaking up what you can
that's what i mean by goodish i don't
mean like
oh too bad like i guess i'm not you know
i mean the exact opposite like i am
gonna
own this um thank you for telling me
that
oh wow i had no idea i'm gonna go look
that up
i appreciate you bringing it to my
attention that's that's the kind of
um outcome and that's where this idea
that
that kind of feeling like we've messed
up feels yucky
is problematic because one thing causes
to do is if we don't have mechanisms to
have a growth mindset and kind of get
over that yucky feeling
it can cause us to do a number of bad
things one of them is just to deny that
we've messed up at all right
right absolutely yeah and that's that's
of course
you know the most harmful because
um not only are we not learning if the
context in which that's happening is
someone saying
you know if if uh if i have a student
saying to me you know i think that
reading you a sign like there was just
nothing but white
uh voices represented in that reading
and i kind of like dismissed well you
don't understand
my field and you know which by the way
is exactly the dialogue that goes
through my head
like how dare you and don't you know
um but when i can sort of like there it
is those are my red flags those are my
triggers that's that's my good person
person responding when i can when i can
flip it
you know to not deny them i'm actually
also now creating a space where where
their lived experience is valued
right as opposed to doing double harm
first i made the mistake
and then i told them their lived
experience wasn't legitimate
i i said to them well it's not raining
where i am so i guess it's not raining
where you are
that's in essence what i do with denial
and the key with that is that you have
to have this
vision first of all that you don't have
to fight it because it doesn't mean
you're a bad person
it's giving you this opportunity to
learn something new which is actually
cool you can be this like
nerd in the like social justice
classroom where you're like oh
this is a new you know this is the thing
that wasn't on my radar yet how can i
learn and do better there i think that's
a great way to put it i never thought of
it that way but i think that's sort of
what i've become
it's not that i don't like sometimes lay
awake at night
mortified by it and it's by no means a
game
but it is it it there there's this like
satisfaction with getting better at it
and knowing that
um the harm i've done in the past i can
i can lessen that
in the future and and it's what it's
worth noting that this is hard i mean a
lot of the social psychology research
suggests it's really
easy to fall into these fixed mindset
patterns where we
kind of go off and deny stuff and so
just to get some of the science on the
table
talk to me about one of these ways that
we end up denying privilege in this
interesting
way which has a funny name it's called
this bias called the hard knock life
effect let's just talk through that to
get it on the table here
oh sure i love that study it's by um by
my colleague taylor phillips at
nyu and and her co-author brian lowery
um at stanford i love that uh
paper so what they talk about with the
hard knock life effect so so first this
context
the the phrase hard knock life is
referring to a song
in a broadway musical in a movie called
annie
don't worry
that's awesome lori um by the way that's
the third time i've got someone to sing
live in the last
week on a zoom of some sort so so i'm
keeping track
um so in the song that you just heard
the heart it's a hard knock life
it refers to this this sort of the
challenges adversity that ones face
particularly in childhood so in this
particular set of studies what they did
was they asked people to think about
their childhood and to reflect on the
hardships and adversity of their
childhoods
but the the variable that they
manipulated in their studies
is sometimes they just ask people to do
it and sometimes it i believe
um i can't remember if they ran white
participants and black participants
but they definitely had white
participants in this study so
so in one in one condition they simply
said uh
you know tell me about your childhood
adversity
and in in the other condition the
instructions were slightly different for
those participants they
they before they said tell me about your
childhood they said
they gave them uh a quick little
sentence that said something about
uh the advantages that white people have
um had in versus blacks in the united
states
and so it was basically a statement of
what we would call group advantage it's
not saying you individually had those
advantages but as a group
and what then they looked at what the
responses were and what they found
was that people essentially rewrote
their personal histories like they
it doesn't even appear that it was
necessarily a conscious like they don't
have evidence it was a conscious process
but that
they they literally cited more
challenges and more adversity in their
lives
in the condition where they were
reminded of group advantage
and so i what i take away from these
studies
is this this this how
hard our minds will work even without us
directing it consciously to protect our
identities
that good person identity that deserving
person identity
that i have not taken any advantage uh
away from anyone else and so um in those
studies
what what people were revealing i think
if i remember right in the papers they
were
that the the the scholars were saying
that
while group advantage a lot of people
buy into group advantage they found
evidence that people didn't necessarily
dispute
that there were these group advantages
based on race
what they what they resisted was that
they individually
incurred that group advantage and so
that's where that's where this hard
knock life
retelling of our personal histories
kicks in and so so
so you know there's some there's some
like work we have to do around we
intellectually understand
a lot of this data but do we really
internally
accept that we may be beneficiaries of
it
that we may be in fact even propagating
it
um and the data suggests we are we are
beneficiaries and we are propagating it
you know you know depending on what
dimension of identity we're talking
about but if we're not black
we're probably benefiting from some
biases um
racial biases that are deeply hurting
others
yeah and the power that you know without
us realizing it
our minds are just going to go to data
like they're just going to look up
statistics
that make us feel like oh we personally
couldn't have been as privileged like
other white people other straight people
you know other you know ivy league you
know employees like they benefit but not
me personally i mean
that's right striking um and so so this
is all in the domain of
you know trying to have a growth mindset
so that when when things are pointed out
to you
like you can not deny them you cannot
try to like
you know find other evidence and so on
but there are other ways that our kind
of
good person mindset gets in the way too
even in cases where we're like
trying to act um and that's kind of what
you refer to in the book as something
like cookie seeking
oh yeah yeah um so talk a little bit
about this because this
these are cases where we're we're not
denying like we're actually
we're trying to take action to fix
things but we're doing this in a way
that's like a little bit kind of
benefiting us rather than the people
we're trying to help
yes absolutely yes so the freeze cookies
thinking
this is another one where i don't know
who to attribute it to we tried hard to
figure out the original source but
it's a phrase that is used pretty widely
in activist communities
um and it speaks to this centering we
sometimes do
so um you know let's say
uh i have a black colleague and um
you know i've lately been trying to
educate myself i've i've you know i went
and read the new
jim crow um i read cast
i read the warmth of other sons and so
so
i sort of somehow find a way to work it
into my conversation
in this example i'm not black i'm me i'm
not black
um i somehow find a way to work it into
a conversation
with my black colleague you know because
i'm sort of waiting for them
you know again it may not be totally
conscious but um
i say it and then i like do that little
micro pause where you're waiting to be
like oh
oh good for you you know like that's a
little bit of a cookie seeking behavior
you know i noticed myself even doing it
like outside of issues around identity
even in like my own marriage you know
that
um my husband right now during the
pandemic is
his work is outside the home uh so
really i should be feeling bad for him
he's you know
an essential worker out there but but
instead i'm home with the kids and so
when he gets home i sort of do all sorts
of like
i don't overtly whine but i kind of drop
in a whole bunch of like how hard today
was kind of little waiting
with those little micro pauses to be
validated
to be given a cookie and
that's all fine and good except for the
fact that what i've just done there
is instead of centering the people i'm
trying to support if we go back to my
black colleague
i'm reading those books because i am
trying to do better
when it comes to racism but instead what
i've done is just
added to the burden of racism because
i've now asked this
colleague to see me and validate me and
it's exhausting and it happens on a
constant basis in big ways in small ways
that's what cookie seeking is and the
story i tell in the book about it is um
is a former student of mine actually who
uh identifies as queer and and worked
at the time a very progressive company
in san francisco in the bay area
and the orlando pulse shooting happened
you might remember
we woke up that sunday morning to that
news
she was grief stricken all day sunday
and then a sunday night approached and
she thought about going to work on
monday
at a company that had all sorts of
progressive policies and progressive
people
and like you know she was dreading going
to work
why was she dreading not because people
wouldn't care not because there would be
bigotry
but because there would be so much
cookie seeking
she knew everybody would be coming to
her trying to be
seen trying to be validated oh you know
i
been donating to the trevor project for
years or
you know my gay college roommate and
she felt she had no more emotional
reserves
to support them that she needed to be
seen and heard rather than
helping them be seen at her so that's
what cookie seeking refers to
yeah and i think that this is something
that comes up a lot i think for our
black students and staff members in the
context of what we've been going through
in 2020 where again well-intentioned
people who are believers in equity but
because they kind of have that
i want to be seen as a good person
mindset end up putting more emotional
labor
on black people because they're trying
to like show off how
woke they are about these kinds of
things and so exactly wilson
um and so so all of these things from
denying the privilege
to you know kind of seeking out some
data that make you feel better about
your privilege oh it wasn't me this sort
of hard knock-like effect
even the cookie seeking these are all
cases where like because we really
really want to be a good person
we like deeply get it wrong even though
we're a believer and so now i want to
stretch to strategies we can use to like
be the builder right like not just rely
on the living part
and kind of use that goodish mindset to
kind of get a little bit further
and so i want to start with that on the
privileged side about just the act of
seeing it right so what are some tips
given that we know we're likely to deny
it or just lots of things about the
headwinds and tailwinds mean we don't
see these things
what can you do to like you know
actually look there you know to kind of
take your spy goggles on and put it on
and see
the privilege and the structures that
you're benefiting from yeah
absolutely well i think the first thing
we can do is is really just start
noticing what's happening around us i
mean this is the classic you know
uh yesterday my i said you know
uh gosh we're some reason we have no
pens in this house i cannot find a
working pen and my husband's oh
we just i just bought some pens they're
in the junk drawer so i open the junk
drawer
and i'm like there's no pens in this
junk drawer like i am looking there's no
and he comes over and he's like
yeah you mean this entire pack of big
pens right in front of you
so part of it is we got to start seeing
the big pens right in front of us and
the way i think we can do that is some
audits
around uh what is like the daily
consumption we're doing
so whatever it is you consume movies
podcasts tv shows
music um you read whatever
we're all consuming something in some
form news
audit the last 10 units
of that that you did uh how much
diversity of voice is in there how much
diversity of identity
how similar are those identities to your
own
look at your social media sorry i forgot
to say social media is a really
big piece of consumption for for many of
us um
one really concrete place we can start
is to say
let's look at let's audit my last 10
units of x
and figure out how if in fact there
isn't enough
um range of perspectives and identities
in there and enough
difference from ourselves and for almost
all of us there isn't
i can actively start changing that
that's an action we can
easily take by doing that we start to
notice things we haven't noticed before
you know i tell a story in the book
about when i was a kid
i my parents sort of passed down this
clock radio that was
that was broken and and it turned out
where it broke was on a particular black
radio station
and so as a young kid when i didn't
really understand that there were like
different radio stations for
for white music and black music so i
grew up hearing like black
um talk radio in the morning and black
black music of course but also black um
tellings of news events
and of course there was a wide range of
black perspectives that i heard on that
station
and when i got old enough to realize
that there was more than one radio
station in the world and that
other radio stations were sort of saying
different things it was this like
whoa noticing moment um so i'd say right
there is one place we can start today
to begin to notice things we haven't
seen before the perspectives we haven't
we haven't tuned into before
and last thing i'll say on that
particularly if it's on social media
that you're doing this
when we start to tune in to
conversations we weren't hearing before
it's very important that we treat we
treat it as if you were
eavesdropping in a coffee shop chances
are by politeness norms you wouldn't
insert your com
yourself into that conversation you're a
guest you're an eavesdropper
um so so the opportunity is to listen
not to argue not to justify not to say
all
white people not all women all men
whatever
it's simply to pick up stuff we're not
hearing and i think another thing you
said in that piece of advice i wanted to
kind of like double down on which is
that
you said kind of consuming these things
right like this
you didn't say you know talk to your one
queer colleague about what it's like to
be queer or demand that your black
colleague like explain to you how she's
feeling
after the most recent police shooting
like there
there's content that already exists out
there you shouldn't
ask people for emotional labor to tell
you what to look at right
that's right there there is no shortage
of
you know and and that's which isn't to
say that we should be silent what we
want to do
is um if there's a terrible shooting
of an unarmed black person there is
value
in saying to a black colleague i just
want you know i'm thinking of you and
your family
is there anything i can do to support
you is there anything i can take off
your plate today like
i just want you to know i don't know how
you're doing today but i just want you
know i see you
there may be value in that of course you
have to judge the individual
relationship and context
so silence is actually quite destructive
those moments but that's different than
saying
can you tell me how you feel when you
get pulled over
i mean like that's asking a lot and then
well i don't understand but if you just
you know put your hands you know like
that's emotional labor
right right and so that's one
distinction but i think a bigger thing i
think we need to do to kind of be
builders
is like how we deal with the moments
when
our mistakes are pointed out and one of
the things i think you're incredibly
frank about in the book
is that one of the reasons we can't be
good people right now is that we're
probably all gonna mess up right you're
not yourself
if you are yourself from any identity
that is not marginalized
because of the headwind tailwind thing
you're not gonna see stuff and you
are gonna screw up is that a hundred
percent
i did i did um i had a conversation with
somebody i really respect last week
who who is reading my book or i just was
in the middle of reading my book when i
spoke to her
um this is someone i don't know well i
know
of her and this was the first time i was
speaking with her and
and she said can i share with you um
i love your book blah blah but uh you i
noticed you sent her whiteness
and i was like yeah oh all right uh what
do you mean by that
and and she proceeded to read a section
of my book aloud to me
in which it was really clear i had
centered whiteness and the way i had
done it is
i had in that particular section of the
book i hadn't even like
named that i was doing it but i was
speaking to white people
without even naming i was doing it it
was just sort of as if the default
is whiteness and so i i can now speak to
you without even saying okay
white readers this this little bit might
be more useful to you than to others
um i did not do that consciously
i'm that is not the type of book i meant
to write um
and uh and yet i'm not at all surprised
it happened
you know i have also grown up trying to
you know
fit in as a into a community of
whiteness so
so the response in that moment is really
critical
of i felt the the fixed mindset rising
but because i know to look for it i was
like oh my gosh
what a gift that's the moment i have to
save myself what a gift what a gift
she's telling me what a gift she's
probably
the millionth person who's thought it
but she's the one who's actually telling
me
and so so walk me through kind of what
are the right reactions in those cases
because i'm sure everybody again
everybody on this webinar is going to
experience it for some identity that
they might not see
themselves yeah absolutely so if if the
situation is some like the one i just
gave where somebody's like
live or you know an email or whatever
giving you information about something
they noticed that you didn't um that
that's the key moment to say
first and foremost it buys you time and
it's what you mean
thank you thank you first and foremost
wow thank you um the second thing to say
is i want to understand what you're
saying
if you don't understand what they're
saying uh you know
can you tell me like oh you sent her
whiteness in the book
wow thank you can you tell me where you
saw me do that
the person may have the stamina to do
that and they may not
and if they don't that's not on them
it's on me
but if you can get an example not
because you're like oh well
prove it it's more like oh wow i am
really grateful you saw something i
didn't so language like
thank you can you tell me more i'm sorry
let's not underestimate the power of
those three words i am sorry
i want to be clear it's three words it's
not i
am sorry that that i offended you or i
am sorry that you were offended or i am
sorry
no it's i am sorry
um we have to own our impact even when
it doesn't match our intention in fact
especially when it doesn't match our
intention
so so i am sorry um
i want to learn more about that you know
meaning i'm going to go learn more about
that or that's
that's really useful for me i'm going to
educate myself on that
or um i'm going to go um
uh review things i've written in the
past and see if i made that same mistake
or you know what i have some data i
could look at to see you know oh you're
saying that my grading
um doesn't feel i'm gonna actually go
back and look at past grading and see if
in fact that pattern does
show up and thank you for giving me
something to test
in the data i have we all have date no
matter what you do for a living
you have some whatever you do is in fact
data your daily actions and daily
behaviors are data you may or may not be
collecting it and documenting it
um but that is in fact data that you
could look at
so let me look at it let me learn more
about it
thank you i am sorry these are all great
places to start that conversation
and so that's that's kind of when you
mess up which is so important right to
kind of react correctly because we're
going to mess up
but there are other things we need to do
as a builder which is to step
up right which is to maybe be the one
pointing out when we notice other cases
of bias or when we notice other cases
and you talk when when somebody who's
not themselves from a marginalized group
uh points this out you talk about that
in terms of
what's called ordinary privilege and so
walk us through ordinary privilege and
kind of why it's so important that
people from non-marginalized identities
use that to fix things
yeah absolutely so this brings us back a
little bit to our headwinds and tailwind
so
you know if we if we think of privilege
um as the places where we have the
tailwinds
and then i'm gonna call ordinary
privilege is the places where i have the
tailwinds that are so
ordinary in my day-to-day life i don't
even think about them so
straightness for me is in the form of
ordinary privilege i don't have to think
about it
because i don't have to navigate it as i
mentioned earlier
and so those parts of our identity
that that we i think there's there's a
national conversation around privilege
where we might feel shame around that
identity if we're willing to acknowledge
it
i'm actually heartened by the studies
the many studies that show
that we actually that ordinary privilege
gives us
influence and so
for example there's studies that show
that
if um a racist joke is told
and a white person says hey that wasn't
cool versus a black person says hey that
wasn't cool
you know controlling for all the things
we control for in good rigorous
experiments
the black person will not be taken as
seriously than the white person who
challenges the racist joke
that there's us a an attribution made
of entitlement or whininess even though
it was the same joke
and the same response so
what did we take from that well the
white person might feel like it's not my
place to speak up on this
so they they might think i shouldn't say
anything but what the data
is saying is that actually you have
more influence than probably a you
realize and b
than the black person will in this
moment which doesn't mean i should talk
over the black person
but it does mean that i shouldn't be
silent or
accepting and in that moment i think we
have
ordinary privilege that we can access
the part of my identity i think about
least
which possibly for for some white people
might be their race that might not be
the first thing that comes to mind when
you think of your identity
um that might be the exact place where
you have more influence than you realize
your ordinary privilege
and it's also just kind of it's perhaps
more effective or at least that's what
the data suggests it's more effective
if in this case of a racist joke if
you're a white person you speak up
it's also like helpful and that like you
know
it sucks more like if you're the black
person who's sitting there when a racist
joke is being told or a racist
statement's being said right like
there's just such emotional labor that
you go through you're from a
marginalized identity
that to like take that labor off the
plate of the marginalized person could
be incredibly powerful in all these
contexts from racism
to all this exactly and that's exactly
right
and then the third benefit i will add to
that is that
we it looks like we tend to
underestimate we think oh it's not going
to matter if i say anything the person
is going to get defensive or argue with
me or belittle me
and that's true that often does happen
but what
studies also show is there does seem to
be an impact though
in the behavior of the individual not
always i'm not
claiming this is always going to happen
but they're there
we see we interpret a defensive response
as we got nowhere
the data suggests otherwise that's great
to hear and that was actually i would
say one of the most common questions we
received
before this webinar is this question of
like how do i engage when i hear these
tiny micro
not tiny but like you know important
questions at work um you know how do i
like point out bias without seeming
holier than now i guess
that's the kind of interesting thing
that these data show is that as the
pointer outer
you're focused again kind of on yourself
like i don't want to seem holier than
that
i don't want to seem like a snob or it's
not my place but actually
if you're in a good-ish mindset what
you're paying attention to is the
outcome
right like you want these behaviors to
stop you want to fight these systems and
these structures that make things feel
so unequal for people from different
backgrounds
i think that's exactly right like we if
we're centering our own comfort if we're
not willing to spend
some of that comfort than that we are
centering ourselves
i mean there is value though in thinking
about again back to heat and light like
let's be intentional if that's for you
going to be a light based moment where
you actually want to change
minds then you're going to have to think
about like what influence strategies are
you going to use
if that's going to be a heat based
moment where you just want to make the
other person
very uncomfortable and challenge what
they did and puncture the norm
then then you can take that approach and
be effective in that kind of way
um but but absolutely we we
in in that moment when the the the um
the opportunity to speak up happens
uh we if we
wait for it to feel comfortable we
almost never will
and that i think is just a message that
i think everyone on this call needs to
hear right like
this is supposed to be uncomfortable
right it is almost
always uncomfortable for people from
certain identities right like they don't
get to avoid this discomfort
that's exactly right i'm so glad you
said that i was trying to
like string that thought together and
didn't quite get there exactly
like we if if if
if the discomfort of living in a society
where racism
occurs on a daily basis is being born by
black people and they can't walk away
from that
then why should the rest of us be able
to walk away from that that is in fact
what
privilege means right and so we kind of
have to dive in and so then
then let's get to some like practical
strategies for the the final kind of
thing we talked about that we can end up
doing if we're in that good mindset that
we don't want it doing which is the with
the cookie seeking
stuff right they're like kind of
centering yourself as hey
i'm this woke person and i'm trying to
do good um how do we get over that
yeah well i mean the first thing is like
just
just stepping
into okay let's do it this way like
everybody right now think about
something
that you've gotten better at you know
like
baking basketball
anything bulgarian like i i was trying
to go with the bees
whatever think of just take a moment in
your mind think of the thing you got
better at and think about how it felt at
the beginning when you started doing it
and then how it felt as you got better
and if you were to sort of come up with
one word to describe like the emotion
of that um and when i do this with
students
they say things like exhilarating or
proud
or struggle or um
better you know that's the feeling
we want to have in this domain and we
can
what we tend to have in this domain is
feelings like shame
and you know discouragement or confusion
or things like that so we want to
replace like we really want to
come at this from a place of
it feels good to get better at something
and i can get better at this this is
being goodish this is a growth mindset
um and then once we do that like
i think we can begin to act in ways
that we haven't acted on before that
aren't cookie seeking instead of sort of
showing to others what we're doing we're
now almost like
you know showing to ourselves we're
seeking the cookie from ourselves if
that makes any sense
that we are in fact noticing things
acting on things
asking questions you know sometimes it's
literally can we ask
some questions um you know well
uh you know for this particular job that
we're hiring for i notice the job
description says
uh must have a four-year college degree
you know
can i ask about that what what what what
what do you see as essential in
in the job description around the
four-year college degree i mean it's
worth asking a question
or um i noticed that um
you know in meetings uh i noticed that
people always sit you know in this
particular configuration i guess
we don't sit in meetings anymore but
like but you know what i mean
um or or i noticed that that you know we
we um we invite
these people to the zoom and we we don't
include this level of employee
i was wondering about that i wonder if
we've ever tried inviting
the full staff to the zoom discussion um
just asking questions begins a process
so we're not always in a position where
we feel like we can just make
change or even articulate the change
we'd like to see
but we can almost always ask questions
and this gets to kind of my last uh
thing i wanted to talk to you about is
that you know so far we've been talking
about
how we should strive to be goodish
people you know but you're here as part
of this event where we're talking about
belonging at yale and so i wanted you to
riff
a little bit on how we can become kind
of good-ish organizations or good-ish
universities right
are all the strategies that you just
talked about for the individual people
watching this right now
you know how do those apply in the
context of like yale university say
yeah absolutely um i mean that's that's
actually i think
one of the the coolest things that i
um i felt my own
understanding emerge in working on this
book was i'm trained to think about
individuals like as a social
psychologist
um but there was this realization
that what individuals are the
part of institutions and communities and
that
what we are noticing the butter we're
not noticing they're in the fridge or
the
the pens we're not noticing in the junk
for that what we're not noticing are the
systems around us
so when we start noticing more when we
we give ourselves permission to notice
more
and then we do notice more we will start
those systems will become visible
so um if i was a member of your
community
i would just start to to think about the
ways in which
i might be benefiting from certain
systems
and what are the ways in which i could
start nudging others
to notice that that noticing as well and
the best way to do that by the way i
think earlier you mentioned the holier
than thou and i don't think i address
that directly
the best way to do that is to make your
own learning visible to others
um and what that means is this isn't
about i know more than you
this is about i i have been trying to
figure something out
and hey like we're all working on this
big puzzle you're on that part i'm on
this part i think i got this corner
figured out let me tell you
how how to do it um and so making our
own learning visible to others
is really powerful so i think in the
community at yale there's just
there's a tremendous opportunity to
assume
that there's systemic problems let's
just assume it's true
i promise you it is there's no way yale
as amazing place as it is
has somehow been immune from 400 years
of history
and and you know widespread isms in
society
so the question isn't do our systems
need to be addressed it's just
how and then i think another thing you
talk about in your book a lot which i
think is important in the context of
organizations too
is kind of passing the mic right like
when you get the opportunity really to
listen to people from different
backgrounds
and hear what their lived experience is
like yeah that's really powerful
and that's another way in which we
cookie seek is we talk
more than we listen um there's a
great uh little acronym that michael
bungay stanier
uh came up with called it was in a
completely different context it was
context
of coaching but he calls it the weight
rule
the why am i talking rule
i've found that really useful
um in every context not just these
contexts like the kinds i study but in
all contexts
why am i talking rule um but
particularly
when we cookie seek we are usually
talking there's almost always
words coming out of our mouths
yeah and then i think that sort of
builds up to like
another question which is this idea that
you know we
if you're from a majority group you're
often benefiting from these structures
right like when we think about the
structural changes that we'll make at
yale
evening things out means that there's
going to be some people who are kind of
having the tailwinds kind of go down a
little bit
but there's this worry that that might
mean you know the headwinds are going to
go down a little bit too
and so what advice do you have for
people who kind of want to make these
systemic changes
when they realize they might be kind of
facing the possibility that some people
perceive
you know things getting more just as
things getting unfair
you know for the like the
non-marginalized folks who kind of feel
like
well you know why would i as a white man
have to talk less or why would i as a
straight person have to you know think
differently or why would i as
able-bodied person have to worry about
you know text on my screen or something
like that like what advice do you get
when you kind of get that criticism
brought to you
yeah well we i have some um
it's unpublished data it's a paper we're
still working on but
we've got some data that suggests that
what helps us stay
engaged or get more engaged in those
moments is
connecting um connecting it to a bigger
picture
so and this is very consistent also with
like uh
sort of classic work in psychology
around affirming the self
and creating affirmations uh i don't
mean like affirmations like things you
stand in the mirror and look at but
and say to yourself but but just uh in
in the jargon of our field
um sort of uh reflecting on your own
values is one form of affirmation and
what research shows is that when you
connect
those those moments that you're
experiencing those
that are specifically around you and
your
interests and your ego if you can if you
can connect it to a bigger
picture that seems to create greater
resilience for us
around our self-image around our ego
it is true in any one given moment there
might be a fixed pie
right in any one given moment there
might be you know one job
or or one whatever
but in the grand scheme of things we
tend to
underestimate how much the pie can grow
you know in negotiations research they
see this all this time they call it the
mythical fixed pie
that we think my loss is your gain and
vice versa
when in fact there's actually many more
opportunities for
multiple people myself and others to
gain than i realize
um i also you know if i if i'm to be a
little more
kind of pushy on this
i would say uh i don't even think we
have the option
to wait anymore and i i think that
moment came and went
where you can sort of choose to opt out
of these conversations
um i i think we're now in the midst
of dramatic change long overdue
and uh it's
it's time as a builder to sort of figure
out what your role is going to be in
advancing that change
as opposed to worrying about if the
change should happen
or if the change will benefit me the
change is a lot
better chance of benefiting you if
you're part of it
than if you're resisting it um and so i
think that's true no matter how you look
at it in terms of
cultural norms in terms of demographics
in this country
i think in terms of sort of what skills
are being valued by employers
and admissions officers no matter how
you look at it
one is better off taking the stance of
i'm going to be
building this change and part of it than
as opposed to
questioning it and resisting it and then
my final question for you tonight
kind of talks a little bit about where
we are in 2020 right now
where you know these conversations are
more needed than ever more important
than ever
but they can also be a little bit
exhausting and so this is kind of ending
with a little bit of a personal question
you know you are you know central in
this fight for
justice central in this fight of
referring and kind of getting people to
think about being good-ish people and so
on
but that fight can be kind of exhausting
sometimes and i think you know on behalf
of all of our activists is a number
another set of questions that we got a
lot of is like how do you kind of
protect your mental health and the face
of this stuff you know how do you
protect your mental health in the face
of like you know
turning on the heat when people really
seem like they're not listening or even
you know giving
light and you know doing the light
version and getting a lot of pushback
right like how do you protect yourself
in the face of all this stuff
yeah it really is exhausting and it is
important because we want
people in it for the long haul um you
know i wrote
uh back in june uh you know
maybe three weeks after george floyd was
murdered
i decided to start this newsletter that
you referred to earlier dear good people
and and it was exactly for that reason
it was that i was seeing um folks who
were already exhausted now
really exhausted um and then other
people sort of joining the conversation
or trying to deepen their investment and
i was worried about
by july august september october where
was everyone going to be
was it where were our exhausted people
going to be burned out and where are
newer people going to have lost interest
or confidence
um so i wrote this piece called the 10
more rule
and um it's on my website dollychuck.com
newsletter but i'll just i'll just
summarize it
uh basically i think what we all want to
do
is 10 more if you're new to this
conversation
um or new to this understanding
then 10 more means means uh
be 10 more mortified like don't look
away
keep keep stay engaged does it that
means we need you to keep reading and
watching and listening and learning
if you've been in this conversation um
you know you've hashtagged you've
donated you volunteered
that kind of thing um but you know if
this was a basketball game you were
spending more time on the bench than
in the game taking hard fouls um now
it's time to be ten percent
uh more terrified that means get in the
game
take a hard foul take a risk essentially
start saying things at work start asking
questions start
reaching out when start spending your
comfort
and then finally to the group you just
referred to um those who've been
on the front lines fighting so hard a
great detriment to themselves at times
they're in every way physical emotional
financial
um the ten percent more refers to ten
percent more in these i'm gonna do air
quotes
satisfied and by that i mean
not satisfied with the state of affairs
at all
but satisfied that you can come out of
the game
you can you don't have to play every
minute
you can let everyone else get in the
game a little bit
learning about the game and playing the
game you can step
out and catch your breath 10 more than
you have been
and then come back in and i think that's
the key is that if we're going to be
sustainable in this
um the one of the metaphors i share in
the book that uh
someone i interviewed uh offered me as a
flock of birds
apparently when you see the formations
of birds flying about this time of year
that the lead bird the one that's
fighting those headwinds
is rotating it isn't always the same
bird which i did not know
but it's for this exact reason that if
the lead bird was going to stay this
lead bird all the way to their final
destination
they literally aren't going to make it
to the final destination so let's rotate
out so
um i would say 10 more
if you're on the front lines means 10
less essentially not forever just
catching your breath
well i love i think this is a fantastic
place to end because honestly i think if
we really want to achieve belonging at
yale
if literally all the hundreds and
hundreds of people on this call
did 10 more at yale of working to be a
good-ish person
um and fighting so that everyone at yale
feels like they belong
i feel like we'd make a lot of progress
towards making this institution a better
place
but i wanted to end by thanking dolly so
deeply i know i hope you all
see now why she's so fantastic and her
work is so fantastic
again just to give her a couple plugs
you should check out her book
which i think she'll hold up right now
if she's sitting right near it um her
book the person you need to be how good
people fight bias
it's fantastic and really worth a read
you can also even if you need more
bite-sized chunks check out her
newsletter which you mentioned
deargoodpeople which you can check out
at dollychug.com
newsletter thank you everyone for
joining today and for joining the fight
uh to get yale to be a place where
everyone belongs
um i hope i will see you at the next
anti-racism webinar you know
stay tuned to yale news where you'll
hear more about that um ibrahim kendi
will also be fantastic
and thank you to all the organizers for
putting this together really appreciate
having you here today
thanks